how did you get started in the business
okay so I study film and college at NYU
I always wanted to be a filmmaker movies
that kind of stuff and I learned how to
work the camera and and why you film and
made some student films stuff like that
and then I switched paths at college and
went to study something else and gave up
film regretably and after college I went
to Wall Street and I was there fer yes I
was I was working on Wall Street from
about 95 till 2000 and I was miserable I
just hated it I really hate it I wanted
to make movies or write or do something
creative and I spoke to a good friend of
mine named Michael judge wonderful guy
really interesting guy Michael with a
why worth looking into and I said
Michael I'm miserable I hate what I'm
doing I'm making money and so forth but
I really want to do something creative
I'm scared though you know I it's I
don't know what it is exactly I want to
do but I'm afraid to let go of what I'm
doing because I'm making money and so
forth and it's a it's a clear path but
I'm really miserable in fact I had a
girlfriend at the time and I said I just
want to quit my job and just write maybe
make a movie and she laughed at me she
actually laughed at me she was like you
just can sit around all day and write
and and I spoke to Michael and I said
this is what I want to do I want to just
quit and and he said you have to do that
he said think about what the world would
be like if people did what they were
afraid to do I was like okay thanks and
I didn't do it for another couple years
so but several years 2005 ish I spoke to
a good friend of mine named Gary Winnick
who was a filmmaker and I said the same
thing basically I'm miserable I really
want to make a movie at that point I had
written one script it wasn't very good
but I had completed it started and
finished it and
was a good feeling and ice again I said
I'm miserable I hate what I'm doing and
he said the technology right now is
incredible there's a new camera that
just came out called the dvx 100 which
is a very sort of cinematic look to it
when I had been at NYU film school video
was sneered at it was you know it was
garbage there was actually a coffin at
lean against the wall of the film
department at NYU and spray painted on
it was death to video because video was
very um it just looks shitty it just
looked very one-dimensional and cheap
and it was clearly video and this new
technology in about two thousand four or
five there was texture to it and it was
it was cool it really looked cool so he
said just get the camera and just
it just make it so that's basically what
I did I quit my job I wrote this script
I was interested in this topic monogamy
and I knew I was gonna direct it and
write it myself and I was just like yeah
it so I made that movie and that
was sex and sushi and that's sort of the
short version that sort of led to my
somebody saw it in New York and wrapped
it and it played some festivals and then
I moved out to Los Angeles and somebody
else saw it and asked me to write
something else that got produced and
yeah that was it though I believe you
mentioned earlier that you felt you'd
learned everything from film school
within the first six months yes two
weeks I mean once you learn I work the
equipment it's you know I mean it's sort
of a separate conversation in my view
college in general like I think college
is a racket frankly unless you're gonna
be a doctor or whatever we really you
know does the world need English
literature majors and stuff like that to
spend a hundred grand it's like just
spend five grand you know get books and
stuff like that so film school I think
you know is valuable to a certain degree
but for me once I learned how to work
the equipment I don't need somebody
telling me you know screenwriting fear
and all that kind of for my
experience is the best way to learn how
to make movies is to a do them and B
watch them and you know listen to D do
DVD commentary thank you yeah so yeah
once I learned how to work the camera it
was kind of like okay I get it
let's move on this script that you wrote
while you were still working on Wall
Street where did you start formulating
the idea and actually how did you start
seeing like the story structure and all
that I mean you're so you're working
what like crazy hours on Wall Street but
you still had time to write the script
or were you fitting it in I just made
time I mean you can make time to do
something like particularly something
like that where it's you know it's not
really laborious it's not it's fun so
you know your impression of Wall Street
maybe it's not off base but there's time
to do it believe me those guys have
plenty of time to party and drive
Ferraris and so there's time to
write a script and I don't remember how
long that process took but we just sorta
I don't even remember I remember the
script but I don't remember how the idea
came to be it was it was just an idea
and I was like let me try to write it I
think I probably read some scripts and I
knew it wasn't I was gonna try to sell
it or anything or even make it it was
just sort of an exercise but with sex
and sushi I was clear that I'm gonna
write this thing that I'm going to make
into a movie myself and that was a quick
process to I I had an idea and I just
sort of I was listening to somebody
talking about their method recently and
they say they start with the story when
I don't I start with a character for me
sometimes it's a theme or some something
I want to explore but it's certainly
with a character it's not a necessarily
a story and I just sort of get you know
I sort of fill in that character he's a
sort of a skeleton and once I'm really
happy with that character he or she in
fact I'm running something now with a
female lead but I sort of point them in
directions and just see what happened
and this story comes from that
that's not really answering your
question but yeah so the theme of it was
monogamy and you decided to write it how
long did it take you to finish sex and
sushi they actually writing
yeah the writing portion maybe mmm six
weeks six weeks okay a month it was
quick it was all I did I mean it was and
it was just like and I knew I was
probably an act in a too and it was the
film the finished film is I'd say it's
30% improvised that said there was a
very deliberate hard and fast script but
we definitely deviated from it
but you know if I'm if I'm engaged in a
project if I'm writing a script and I'm
into it
you know that's all I'll do and it's
quick I wrote a script not one going two
weeks and I was really amped about it
you know it's all I thought about it's
all I wanted to do Robert did you quit
your job and then make sex and sushi how
did that all work out it was that's
pretty much how it worked out I was just
like I'm done initially I think it was
I'm gonna take a leave of absence kind
of thing I was running a hedge fund at
that point so it wasn't like I was
working for some entity so I just
basically shut it down and it was I
returned investors money and so forth
and initially it was sort of like let me
just take six months off and see what
happens kind of thing and it became you
know more than six months it's still
going but yeah I just shut everything
down Yeah right
and so you initially had a DP attached
the project what happened with that you
gonna act in it you wrote it right you
had someone you knew starring in it a
female lead I had to shut in no well my
girlfriend at the time played my
secretary and the the opposite lead i I
just met through casting okay yeah but
the DP story is yes so I I didn't have
any experience making a movie and so I
figured let me hire a pro DP who knows
what the hell he's doing and I did that
and and we shot for 3-4 days or
something
and I mean just the first shot I was
told by him that typically the first
days of disaster anyway but I don't know
if that's true but it took him like four
hours to set up this really basic shot
and I was like I guess this is how they
do it what do I know I'd never been on a
set before and after a few days with
this kind of stuff where it has to be
this way and the lighting and the crew
and everything I was like wait a minute
you know even if it does have to be like
this like I'm not comfortable with this
I'm running the show you're not running
it and we had you know he had a bit of
an ego and and I do as well and so we
clashed and I said what about if we just
you know sorted and he was like no no no
so I said finally I just I said you're
done you're out goodbye and the takeaway
for me for that was if this thing's
gonna get up somehow if it's
gonna look shitty or if there's gonna be
something wrong with it I want to be
because I trusted my instincts and I was
wrong
rather than I didn't trust my instincts
and I just let this guy do whatever the
he wanted and you know and I think
there's something to that in terms of
the shooting the spirit of the shooting
really changed the vibe really changed
on the set because it was just kind of
like not like a punk-rock kind of vibe
but it wasn't so you know we're curing
cancer kind of thing and it's got to be
this dogmatic sort of that you know
and addition to which we were making you
know a thirty thousand dollar romantic
comedy it wasn't like we were you know
some serious period piece and heavy
drama in that so so yeah I just I
just shot the thing myself and the
credit the IMDB credit is Walter brute
which is an anagram of Robert long my
name yeah and you funded the film
yourself right right okay are you
forgive me if this is too personal by
are you putting this on a credit card
how are you funding the film one of the
benefits of Wall Street is you know your
credit cards don't get maxed out so yeah
I had money
right you have money and were there
times when you felt like oh this is a
runaway train or one
you kind of took the helm and the DP was
out you felt like this is fun this is
nice it's a good question yeah you know
it's funny I said this at the time and I
repeat it today the IE I wrote it I
directed it I acted it and I DP did I
whatever
and I also produced it and if I just had
to produce it I still wouldn't want to
do it like producing for me I it was I
didn't like it why because you're you
know the it's the kind of stuff that I
like doing the creative and the
acting and all of that stuff and like
what's in the frame and making a movie
but they're getting a location set up
and making sure this person shows up and
like that is a disaster I'd much
rather let you know pay somebody else to
do it I just don't have the temperament
for it in addition to which I almost
maybe have too much of a temperament
before because as a director I'm I am i
micromanage everything you know so if
anything's going wrong in terms of the
ancillary stuff the producer stuff like
that's all think about and it becomes I
get very stressed about it so that that
was that sucked I hated that
yeah I think we're in line and that what
what advice do you have for someone
that's going to pull the cord and and
jump free from a job that brought in a
lot of money a lot of prestige a lot of
people would think wow that's great you
know you're on Wall Street you're
running a hedge fund and then you're
you're saying no I want to make an
independent film now and I'm gonna I'm
gonna break free of this life it's just
like Michael judge said to me he said
think about what the world would be like
if people did what they were afraid to
do I mean so yeah sure there's a safety
blanket and but that what kind of life
is that you know I am
when I was at film school I would be
editing a film that I shot and I would
look at my watch and it was like eight
hours went by and it felt like ten
minutes and that's the kind of feeling
that you know they say if you love what
you do you don't work a day in your life
or something like that so you know it
take the lead you know what I mean or
else just live your whole life doing
something you hate to do and being
afraid to that's no wife you know yeah
right but in the real world too though
there's like an invisible
ability factor sometimes when you switch
over to a creative thing that hasn't
totally taken off and when you're on
Wall Street and you have a title you
know you're respected you know so how
was that
thinking almost like maybe there's going
to be a stigma attached to me leaving
something you mean in terms of it being
sort of a humbling experience to start
at the bottom a little bit because it
sounds a lot of people when they do that
sort of switch of careers it's not just
going from one great position to another
there's there's all for sure yeah you
know I I just for me it got to the point
and remember it took another five years
basically for me to finally so typically
with me I don't really do anything until
my backs against the wall you know like
that's just the way I am so not doing it
just got too overwhelming for me so for
me I I just was thinking like you know I
don't want to live the rest of my life
thinking what if I had tried this kind
of things so I just think you know can
you tell me what you mean by backs
against the wall in this situation like
was it just where like you're basically
in the office and times I was miserable
Karen I mean I was miserable you know so
it's not about the outside stuff you
know the apartment and the cars and
whatever it is it's like if you're not
happy I mean that's that's you know and
I knew there's a court I think it's
Lorca he says something like to burn
with desire and keep quiet about it is
the greatest punishment we can get do
you know put upon ourselves and it's so
true you know I it's just it's after a
while of just being like what if and let
me try plus the technology caught up to
you know people guys were making clerks
and brothers McMullen and like that
and was like I can do this let me just
try it
so yeah that's whatever so what's your
advice for someone else in your same
position maybe they're a doctor lawyer
whatever maybe their physical therapist
whatever it is where it's like there's a
title
a respect factor their family thinks oh
he's doing great
our son is this he's amazing and turns
out our son doesn't want to be there
sure I think it shouldn't be free you
know our son doesn't want to be I need
should be that pert the Sun itself
saying to himself I don't want to be
here a but be it doesn't have to be all
or nothing to you know remember I wrote
a script when I was still working on
Wall Street so it doesn't have to be
like I quit and let me try this jump
into this whole thing it depends on what
the endeavor is but if somebody wants to
be an actor or a writer or whatever you
don't have to quit your job and chained
up and everything so I guess my advice
would be in general pull that trigger
whatever that trigger is for you but you
know you can sort of dip your toe in the
water a little bit yeah for sure but you
know wondering about something like
seeing a girl and wanting to ask her out
I'm just and she never liked I speak for
myself that's happened to me you know
I've seen a girl like I'd love to talk
to her and she I never talk to her so
after a while you're like okay I don't
want to feel that feeling again let me
talk to her this time and you do and you
know whatever happens right so I think
not doing something for me at least is I
have to just kind of keep doing it and
that's what I sort of mean about back
against the wall I learned how to sell
on Wall Street and in my view you know
you can writing or directing or whatever
that's half of it being really topped on
your craft and being excited about and
so forth that's half of it if you can't
sell whatever it is your script or
whatever it is you're gonna be the best
unknown you know script writer out there
so it's sort of a I don't like the idea
of sales
I don't like salesmen I don't really
consider myself a Salesman I don't like
it when I go into a store and somebody's
like all is there a solicitous and this
would look great on you I don't buy it
typically I'm turned off by the concept
of sales but that said hey you need to
do it in a Hollywood my experience you
have to go into a room and pitch the
out of your script or whatever
yourself is a director or whatever it is
and be if
you are genuinely passionate about what
it is that you're selling it's really
not it doesn't be a bad thing and it's
it gets conveyed in your delivery so
that was a really helpful thing for me
in terms of Walter naturally I'm not a
Salesman type I'd rather just be like
okay don't buy it I don't care you know
keeping that theme there so many people
they make these amazing films and they
say well we're gonna get this festival
screening and they do and they have this
great sort of party atmosphere with it
and then the film is finished it's
screened at various festivals and now
comes the distribution portion of it and
I think a lot of people hit a brick wall
and the movie just sits there if it
doesn't get a certain deal and they've
invested not only money but so much time
and energy and hope into this film
what's your advice for people that they
say well I'm an artist I'm not a sales
person I'm not a business person tough
you know like okay then go be an
artist but don't expect to get a
distribution deal necessarily or don't
expect to sell a script or whatever I
mean it's it's just part of the deal you
can be that sort of I'm an artist kind
of guy and do or girl and just DIY it
that's cool do it you know nowadays you
can do that from beginning to end you
don't need to get into bed with somebody
a distributor or whatever it is but you
know it's just part of in terms of the
bigger picture and Hollywood in spec
stuff and studios and you just have to
do it and you know get used to it I mean
it doesn't have to be a such a terrible
thing either it's not like you're
selling some stupid thing that you don't
like really you're selling your movie
you know right it shouldn't be it's not
such an ugly endeavor right so what's
your advice for someone that let's
suppose they are and that artists
mindset and you're like look you have to
be a salesperson you have to wear that
hat can you give them sort of like this
bulletproof or excuse me a bullet point
I should say list of what they should do
to market themselves in their film what
kind of like morning afternoon evening
they should have in terms of like
structuring their time you know it's
kind of off topic but it but it is
somebody hurt to me recently it may sort
of answer
directly I'm really sick we started our
screenplay competition a couple weeks
ago and I've gotten quite a few scripts
and some of them we're very clear in the
guidelines and the rules and so forth
what we want it needs to be typical
screenplay format it's not they're
pretty straightforward rules or
guidelines and I've gotten a few scripts
we've all gotten a few scripts that
aren't formatted correctly or there are
spelling errors on page one oh wow and
I'm hoping we'll do but if you can't
take the time to assign a spellcheck
sometimes like there's one I'm thinking
of we got last week that they misspelled
they meant to type face and they typed
fade instead so spellcheck didn't catch
it but you know that's the kind of stuff
where I'm just like you this is your
thing that you have toiled over and
you're so Pat presumably really
passionate about this is your poured
your guts into this thing and you're
trying to get it out there how can this
happen like those sort of basic things
so I would just say you know make sure
your product is is bulletproof and and
then I just really feel like if you are
genuine about your excitement about the
project it's gonna be conveyed when
you're trying to sell it that said you
might have to accept the fact that I've
written scripts for example that I was
really passionate about and I've had my
manager for so and so on and producers
say it's not commercial and I could just
be like well down but you know what
me because they're right you know
so so that's something you just have to
accept and you can sort of say to
yourself okay I'm gonna you know it's
better to do to find the stuff out
before you make a movie certainly or at
least before you write a script sort of
what the market is looking for and I'm
not necessarily saying you know you
should co-opt your own vision and that
kind of thing depends kind of what you
want to do if you want to be a DIY & D
filmmaker and you sort of go it alone
and you you're not beholden to the
industry and and people's tastes and
stuff like that you're
still gonna have to sell it down the
road but the short answer your question
is I feel if I'm passionate about
something if a person's passionate about
something they'll convey it I mean that
said there are people who are just
genuinely you know they're not they're
kind of shut down personalities and
they're not cool garius so forth so then
I guess the my advice would be you know
link up with someone who is who's who
wants to be on board with you and can be
your sort of point man or woman and deal
with that kind of stuff
sometimes it could be a sales agent but
typically I think it should just be
somebody who's on board part of it part
of the crew yeah crowdsource Studios
first off why did you begin it was there
like a catalyst that something happened
sure yeah good question so um briefly I
had I think I had gotten turned down for
something I had written I don't remember
exactly the what the what the specific
catalyst wasn't on my end but something
made me start digging how many spec
scripts are written every year and I had
always heard like there are like a
hundred thousand spec scripts written a
year I started thinking what happens to
those scripts you know that was sort of
the genesis of it and I did some
research and it's true there are at
least a hundred thousand spec scripts
written every single year which is an
enormous number and granted probably 90%
of them were garbage but there's still a
lot and last year 62 were optioned or
sold out of at least a hundred thousand
that's not an efficient system to me I
don't believe that there I believe that
there were I'm certain there were
scripts that will never see the light of
day that are just as worthy of being
produced being purchased whatever it is
I started thinking about that what's a
you know what's a better way to or
what's an alternative or additional way
to you know I put some light on these
scripts and what about the guy or the
girl who doesn't have a rep and you know
I have a manager so like and to be a
spec screenwriter now
and to be unwrapped you have to
basically send out a bunch of query
letters begging managers to read your
script like please will you read 99
percent of the time you don't even get a
response much listen no a polite no so I
used to always be interested I would
wonder like is there another Bob Dylan
out there somewhere who's just you know
like the world will never know about him
because he or her or whatever because
he's just he's because of luck really
you know the story of prisoners you know
that movie with Hugh Jackman and um
what's-his-name you know a movie with
Jake Gyllenhaal that's a great movies
you see it the way that that movie came
to be the writer Aaron I forget his last
name was working like in a mailroom
somewhere in Albany or whatever and and
he wrote a bunch of query letters to
managers literal letters not emails sent
out oh wow actual letters and one of
them found its way onto I think it was
Adam kohlbrenner at madhouse madhouse
entertainments desk and he just happened
to notice it the return the return I
think of the return maybe was living in
Brooklyn or something and something
about his last name or saw the fact that
he'd actually written a letter sort of
caught his attention so he opened it and
the guy said you know I'm a screenwriter
can I send you a sample of some of my
stuff or whatever so kohlbrenner was
like sure I think it was cold I said
sure send send me some of your stuff so
this kid Aaron sent him I script I think
it was a one or two scripts that he had
written and kohlbrenner said yeah you
you've got something but I don't really
like these scripts what else do you have
so he you know and they ended up
developing and it took years and and
thank God and I think just think about
the the sort of coalescence of luck that
happened that that and now that
wonderful movie came to be just because
he had a coal burner happened to notice
this thing and that's that's terrible
that it should take such a stroke a lock
for that should be a better system in my
you four scripts to get through the the
gatekeepers or to the gatekeepers and
sort of get a fair shot right so so I
started thinking what's a better way to
do that and that's that's kind of the
short answer
medium that's the long answer to how we
started it so you're being turned down
for one of your spec scripts I had
remembered I had written a spec script
that the thing I wrote in two weeks it
was it was a biopic and I was really
amped about it and my manager was like
it's not commercial it's not gonna sell
and I sent it to these producers and
they were like they at the end of the
day they said no and so I started
thinking it's just gonna sit on the hard
drive somewhere and that sucks you know
and forget me what about all these other
guys that don't have producers and
managers to send their scripts to there
there's got to be some worthy scripts
out there and it always bugged me that
just the system of you know query
letters and it's it's it's a shitty
system it's not efficient at the end of
the day so yeah I just started thinking
of an alternative well let's talk about
how crowdsource Studios will work what's
your plan for it is there a website
there is crowdsource studios.com
okay great and then how do people submit
their work sure so I could be the sort
of the broad strokes on what it because
we do because it's not just screenplays
it's not just writing briefly okay so we
say to screenwriters we have a script
competition send us your best low-budget
spec scripts and buy low-budget I mean
think you know blue ruin Blood Simple it
follows any genre send us your best
low-budget spec scripts if you're not
repped we don't care all the better if
you don't live in LA we don't care great
all that yeah so just send us your best
stuff and we meaning crowdsource studios
and the screenplay competition it's
going to be me and other professional
screenwriters are going to judge where
the judges essentially we're the judges
for the finalists we will pick five
finalists based on story
parts for actors budget commercial
viability stuff like that and we will
choose five finalists each finalist has
a page a dedicated page on our website
with their bio including their social
networking handle and stuff like that
bit of info about their script the title
of the genre the logline
and most importantly a video they're
gonna upload a video under five minutes
of them the writer pitching their script
just like they're gonna have to do in a
Hollywood room they have to pitch it and
they show sorry they show you the video
themselves yeah just you know just can
be on your computer or whatever just any
sort of yep absolutely
and then our members Kratz our Studios
members will vote for their favorite
script most favorite pitch whatever it's
based on and so at that point we have a
script and if by the way if anybody
wants to enter its its if you go to our
website you'll see it but it's it's
crowdsource Studios comm and we you'll
figure it out so um there is an entry
fee sorry yeah there's an early bird and
there's a regular and there's a late
deadline and we may extend it and all
that kind of stuff but it's reasonably
priced it's it's less than the average
contest I think the early bird is 20
bucks so then we have a script and at
that point we say I'm gonna at that
point we say directors send same thing
send us your real send us your stuff we
submit to us your your reels we'll do
the same thing professional directors
will judge the directors on entries yep
and each finalist will pick five
finalists based on their reels generally
period or comma and then each director
will have a page on our website with
their bio their reels we will provide
the finalists with a copy of the script
and they will upload a five minute or so
pitch of their vision for the film
and our members have about a month or so
to decide or to vote and then we'll have
a director and we do the same thing with
actors probably simultaneously with
directors we'll do the same thing with
actors we have a part for a 32 year old
woman and a 38 year old man send us your
reels actors we will meaning
professional actors probably producers
probably directors and some
screenwriters too will judge the actors
reels
we'll pick five each one puts up will
have their reel and they'll each put up
an audition they'll pick whatever so
we'll give them this copy of the script
they'll pick a scene or two and the
whole audition and our members vote for
the winners and then we have the
principal elements in place
Robert how will you fund all these
projects for crowd-sourced studios yeah
that's one of the reasons it's we're
called crowd-sourced Studios is once we
have the principal elements the director
of the script the actors then we go to a
crowdfunding site and we raise the
production budget for the film and if
we're successfully funded then we go
make the movie well you have a team of
people trying to be part of the
crowdfunding campaign or how will that
work sure yes so our members the members
of our the people who are voting for the
scripts and so forth those are our
members and and all you have to do to be
a member is to give us your email
address that's it and if you feel like
it vote for you no script or actors or
all three or whatever it is and
hopefully those same people who voted
for the script and the actors in the
director will join us and say yeah you
know what I helped pick the actor or the
script
I'll give ten bucks to get a digital
copy of the film and they'll help yeah
and yeah you know the end game for us is
those same members who helped pick the
actors in the script and so forth and
presumably or hopefully helped us
produce a film raise the budget will be
the end users they'll be the audience
for it so do you plan on directing any
of these films just to be on the safe
side there are a lot of sort of question
marks as you know we want and we have
some sort of control issues
which is a good point because but the
short answer is yeah they're just the
first one I'm gonna direct and somebody
raised the issue what happens if we hire
a nightmare director or we hire so we're
gonna have to you know consider that
when we're picking finalists like do we
want to work with this person and
there's always a wild card with an actor
or whatever it is so we are going by the
sort of Miss America policy which is for
whatever reason we have the right to get
rid of an actor or director whatever it
is probably not a screenplay writer but
it's unlikely that they'll become a
nightmare once we choose the script but
the runner-up whoever got the second
most votes will replace them under you
know if we if we encounter that sort of
a circumstance yeah what if you want to
change a screenplay how much leeway do
you feel cuz you know I know a lot of
screenwriters are very precious about
their work oh you mean if we want it a
little yeah yeah yeah just yeah okay
that's like that's part of the deal
that's part of the contract too so yeah
I mean I've had that experience as a
writer and it's painful and stuff but
you're gonna have to assume that if
we're making this movie it's hopefully
in good hands and you're happy with it
but yeah we absolutely reserve the right
to you know I don't anticipate a major
rewrite hopefully the it's sort of like
when you're making a movie the casting
is 90% of it so when we choose these
finalists we're gonna you know we're
gonna assume that they're not
necessarily camera-ready but they're
pretty damn close but yeah we may we may
do some rewrites right so people can go
to crowdsource studios.com
and they can go on there and they can
submit their work first just screenplays
right now it sounds like that's all
you're taking correct yeah until we have
this we can't really figure out a
director and certainly not actors until
we have the script right okay yep okay
and then any tips to these screenwriters
on how they should present themselves
when they pitch cuz you know some lot of
screenwriters are not they don't feel
maybe comfortable in front of the camera
so how should they
kind of make themselves feel a little
bit more approachable in selling their
stories you know I just think be
passionate about it like you know it can
be at the end of the day it's just you
know we'll decide it's not so much about
presentation although you know you know
if you're dynamic and stuff it it helps
but you need to have a solid story so if
you're really amped about a story that's
like yeah I don't really care you're not
going to win probably but I just think
if the beauty - of doing something like
this just like with actors now most
actors audition on camera I mean on
video they send it around they don't
actually go and show up so you can do it
500 times until you get it right you
know you're the only one so wait till
you get it right and be passionate about
it and it's a you know it's like a
beauty contest in a way you know what I
mean it's like you kind of the most it's
got to be a little bit of definitely
50/50 style and substance I'd say
because again you can have the greatest
pitch and have a shitty script and it's
you know you'll lose and vice versa if
it's all style and no substance you're
not gonna win either right any tips for
writers who were a little more self
effacing because sometimes that works in
your favor if you're Jerry Seinfeld and
sometimes it just comes off as just stop
you know have a little more confidence
in yourself that might work for some
people some people like that you never
know so just sort of be yourself I guess
and if you're really excited I can't
imagine anybody who's pitching their own
script isn't really excited about it so
just figure it out and take your time I
mean you you're uploading a video it's
not live theater or anything so yeah
wherever decide from crowdsource studios
and all of the scripts that you've
written you've also written a book right
rejected true tales of nearly overlooked
greatness you mean this one cares haha
perfect timing
great all right nice happen to have it
happen to be there okay and you dedicate
the book to whom gosh you tell me you
tell me I don't remember well you say
here I'm gonna I have a quote here my
hope is that at least one person out
there will read these true stories of
perseverance despite adversity and
become inspired so you said that it's
dedicated to anyone who's had a dream in
spite of everything who chase his dream
in spite of everything okay yeah yeah
so you wrote it when where were you in
your life well I had just gotten
rejected for something I was up for a
pilot deal with I guess I shouldn't
mention the network and I got turned
down for at the end of the day and and I
had always heard this quote this this
sort of infamous quote the quote was
can't act can't sing bawled can dance a
little and that was infamously said by
the head of RKO casting in 1933 I think
about an unknown Fred Astaire who had
just auditioned for him and it's such a
great story and you know I started
thinking about that gatekeepers and you
know tastemakers and they're not always
right I started thinking I wonder if
there were other stories like that with
famous people who later became famous
and well respected and well-known who
had been rejected early on and I did
some research and it seems it Sam it was
amazing to me how many in all areas from
artists musicians writers I came across
original rejection letter letters like
for Hemingway and so forth and I mean
the Beatles for example they I didn't
know this but in 1962 I think it was New
Year's Day I believe in 62 the unknown
Beatles drove down from Liverpool and
auditioned for Decca Records live in the
studio they did ten songs and the head
of Decca Records was like yeah you guys
aren't going anywhere the Beatles Elvis
was told you know you ought to go back
to driving a truck you're never gonna
make it and there are so many stories
like that
so it was just it was sort of
galvanizing to me it was inspiring to
know that these great you know the the
gatekeepers are often wrong
so yeah that's working about Robert when
I looked through your book rejected it
was fascinating to me to see all these
great names and tech art music that were
turned down and some pretty harsh ways
yeah yeah you know like I think the
Marilyn Monroe when I someone said like
find a husband or dig up secretarial
skills
yeah and I'm wondering how much of
writing a book was actually your own
form of either like cell therapy or like
a letter to yourself it wasn't done so
deliberately but it definitely became
that I am
it was just comforting for me to see
that look everything I've written has
ever made it isn't great and sometimes
you know it's it's right not to get
purchased or whatever but sometimes I
feel like you know they're wrong like
the the gatekeepers or whoever it is you
know what this is worthy this this
shouldn't just die and it was very
comforting for me to see to learn that
so many people had experienced major
rejection and really one of the keys is
I'm sure there are tons of people that
will never hear of in all endeavors all
fields who were rejected five times ten
times one time and were brilliant
whatever it is they did and they gave up
and will never hear about
so perseverance and all that kind of
stuff it was very sort of inspiring for
me to see that that these great artists
had just gone through it and they had to
and maybe they're right or I can't take
this anymore that kind of stuff so it
was definitely comforting to me yeah
have you always had thick skin well
maybe you're not thick skin but does
that play into part I kind of don't have
thick skin really I kind never have had
thick skin I am I
and sometimes I think for me it's it's
definitely a disadvantage in terms of my
stress level kind of stuff like I take
stuff very personally and I I get but
you know it's sort of what you do about
it you know something can be a stumbling
block or it can be a stepping stone and
that kind of thing so yeah I always have
pretty thin skin but you know after all
I guess it becomes thick because you
just sort of soldier through it but
every rejections hurts and and yeah you
don't give off that appearance that you
have thin skin you seem like you're
confident and the things don't get to
you so what's your advice to other
people that they have that living inside
of them because I've seen a lot of great
people give up and become really
disillusioned and leave LA become upset
because they got this one person telling
them something terrible about their work
and it was just that one person and they
just had it right I mean you know I
hesitate to say this because it's kind
of harsh but frankly I think if you're
the kind of person who gives up when you
get some particularly harsh criticism or
you don't really belong wherever it is
so I think you know for me I am I tend
that I have a big ego you know and I
very often will say I have trusted
friends and and people that I will show
stuff to whatever it is a script or
whatever and I'm totally open to
feedback and usually I'll agree with it
sometimes I won't so when I'm about to
send it out to the world and to
gatekeepers and producers and stuff
stuff like that I'm generally in a place
with that material where I feel like
it's bulletproof
so really nothing's gonna get me off my
game where I think yeah maybe they're
right maybe I should just I'm not
supposed to be doing this and before
before I sort of kid you know I say that
mindful of the fact that I've actually
had some stuff produced so what about
the person that never has and they're
like maybe the person's right maybe
these people are right I shouldn't be
doing this to that I would say if you
have this passion inside you like I need
to write a book or write a script or
make a movie whatever just do it
yourself on a very small scale you know
and and then you'd have to worry about
sort of the tastemakers and things like
that yeah did Wall Street strengthen
your your thin skin you think being on
Wall Street maybe I mean because a lot
of Wall Street's dealing with strangers
and people are rude and hang up on you
and and that kind of stuff on business
it's cutthroat for sure down there but I
think just as a function of getting
older you know after being alive for a
certain amount of time you deal with all
this kind of stuff and it either
strengthens you or it squashes you and
you know you're that kind of person or
you're not I just believe that if
somebody has this thing that they need
to do they're gonna do it and there's it
doesn't matter if there are ten thousand
people saying no it's all either gonna
spur them on to continue and you just
put their nose down you know a head down
and or they're gonna just crumble and
they're gonna say okay and that's not
the kind of people we need making stuff
like so let them go back to wherever and
be a plumber that's that's that's life
you know tough right can you get
squashed and then reset I think you have
to kind of get squashed it's just a
question of how you deal with it
I don't know event there probably are
examples of famous whatever's who just
got lucky and right out of the gate they
come this way
you know like you're a star but it's
very unusual I think it's I think it's
an important part you know we talked a
little bit about this before but going
through there's an old saying I almost
don't want to say it because I'm using
it in a script but it's such a dish that
you it's I'll say it now am I gonna say
it all right so um so yeah so yeah I
think you need to sort of get tossed
around a little bit just to strengthen
your resolve and to
you know see what you're made of kind of
thing and I think it's it helps your art
helps all that kind of stuff if you have
it easy you know if you just like boom I
think your art suffers for it I think
it's important to sort of go through
some tribulations yeah Robert what's
your advice for a first-time writer
director for first-time writer director
you mean both or or separately both like
you know somebody that's either in a
career that's flourishing as you were in
or even something that's alright it's a
simple answer don't take it all so
seriously number one for first time
right you know when you're ready for
writers I would say think about actors
when you're writing it's really
important if you want to be a spec
writer and sell scripts Williams Goldman
said it better than I ever could stars
get movies made so think about actors
even if it's not if you're not gonna be
a big spec writer but yeah think about
actors when you're writing and and just
don't take it all so seriously as a
director so sex and sushi 30,000 dollar
film you made it once you left Wall
Street you felt like it was a great
experience for you you did another film
and I believe it was called crave right
okay I didn't do it I wrote it you wrote
it no someone else directed it correct
okay how did all that happen cuz you had
the successful surgery so I 6x knew she
wasn't a great success but it got me
noticed and somebody it got me noticed
by this guy who was a producer who
wanted to direct his first feature and
he said I like that what else do you
have
so I I said I have this idea it's I just
sort of pitched him an idea I had and he
said I like that go write that so I did
and we're a couple drafts of it and we
sort of didn't see eye to eye and he's
eventually said I just want to buy the
script from you and rewrite it and go
make the movie and it was amicable and
he that's what he did and I still
haven't seen the movie to tell you
truth but they made the movie and the
trailer looks awesome by the way yeah I
like cool yeah right oh my god bless him
he's a talented guy the guy who made the
movie rewrote it he's a very talented
guy and visually but I I didn't I read
the shooting drafts and I it wasn't for
me and I remember I was having lunch
with these two great guys Charlie Brill
and Jack burns in right not far from
here
and I was complaining I said I am
miserable I sold this script and they
changed the title they're adding
characters there I was lamenting what
was going on and I was really unhappy I
was think about taking my name off of it
and so forth yep and Charlie said to me
you're a pro screenwriter now you need
to learn this sentence and just say it
all the time
sounds good to me so if the studio says
we want to take your lead actor and make
it a 12 year old Eskimo girl sounds good
to me and that was good advice I needed
to hear that
a B another friend of mine said to me um
you sold a script you know so you should
really be happy about it they're making
it so just you know shut up be happy
most people don't yeah that was good
advice so how important was that for you
to hear that at that time and how have
you carried that with you is that
something that you still say when would
you rein yourself back in when like you
start getting too close to the material
and somebody wants to change something
it depends I mean if somebody's writing
a check and they're paying me like
sounds good to me that's easy but if
it's a spec script and somebody wants to
rewrite it and stuff like that I'm very
typically I'm like yeah I'll consider it
if it's a good idea I'll do it but I'm
all business on my own stuff and I'm not
all business in a different way on your
if you're paying me to do something
whatever you want I'm here to serve you
yeah so your advice too I mean I
understand I
younger screenwriter or somebody just
right out the gate that's like oh but
I've written this and this is so amazing
and they can't change this character and
this and that and aside from the sounds
good to me which is a perfect phrase how
do you teach them to let go of all that
that's a good problem to have you know
that's what I had to learn like keep it
in perspective people would kill to have
that problem so you know if somebody's
paying you they own it it's their
material now I'm sure you're beholding
to it in a certain way and you know you
have to stick to your guns but you know
if it comes down to your vision or
theirs you're gonna lose and you should
in the trailer that I watched for Craig
Ron Perlman's character quoted like this
old Cherokee saying yeah and it was
interesting and it just said sort of
like you know we all have like two
wolves inside of us there's a good wolf
and a bad wolf which willful win and the
old Cherokee grandfather says you know
which one will you feed something ever
you feed more wins right yeah how does
that apply to screenwriting now that's a
stretch but um I think it applies to
living you know it's like if you feed
the bad side of you that's gonna win if
I focus on what's wrong with whatever in
my day is I'm gonna have a bad day if I
focus on what's right with it I'll have
a good day if I focus on the problem the
problem increases and I focus on the
solution the solution increases it's
true with everything not just being
ready are you able to turn off the
problem that much and it's it's
interesting it's just kind of like
there's a saying you know you might the
mind is like a magnifying glass it
depends on where you sort of aim it if
you aim on the problem it's gonna grow
and if you aim on the solution the same
thing so
Rober going back to was it 2005 so when
you made sex and sushi you also acted
right you were one of the main
characters yeah okay how was that for
you as a non actor or maybe you had some
prior experience I didn't have any
experience but again we were making a
sort of a light comedy so it wasn't like
a heavy drama kind of thing and I knew
would be improvised so to me it wasn't a
big deal
I don't think acting is such a big deal
necessarily
I just think it's sort of the same kind
of philosophy like don't take it all so
seriously my girlfriend at the time I
gave her a two-minute acting lesson it
was um don't be afraid don't be scared
if somebody's nervous it conveys its so
either wooden and stiff and that's such
a turn-off to be yourself just be
yourself I know you're playing a
character but just whatever you're
inhabiting that character so just be
yourself and three listen just listen
and it's you know it's um you know it's
not a big deal acting to me and it's
particularly something like that I don't
see the point of taking it too seriously
what do you think about showing actors
the dailies or just just a couple
screenshots oh yeah as I just said it's
you know it's a mistake I mean I had an
actress who I showed regrettably I
showed the dailies to and I was told
never show the Leeds dailies I don't
know that's a common thing but as after
I did so she was so conscious of how she
looked in Decatur it became you know it
was a big mistake so I don't recommend
it yeah I don't know everybody's
different though I mean like for me
again it's not such a big deal and sort
of the yeah it's like it can be loose
and that kind of stuff and some actors
are just you know I think that goes back
to the casting if you're I know I didn't
know any better but and I by the way
she's not in the finished film so I'm
not throwing anybody under the bus who's
in the movie but yeah I mean period
did you watch yourself because you
became then became the DP how was that
for you did you start feeling
self-conscious or did it actually free
you up it totally freed me up it was
just like yeah it's like because you can
tell when someone's up uncomfortable
it's so clear so you know it's how did
it for you why just because it was like
I could see when I was uncomfortable and
I could see when I wasn't when I was
comfortable and you know it's it's it's
it's pretty conspicuous when you're
looking at it
well going back with with some other if
you become a director again on another
project right
you will never I think it goes back into
the casting you mean in terms of
directing actors or just showing an
actor what they look like on screen
before the film is finished I'm not
gonna be I don't think I'm gonna be
casting any anyone who's never acted
before so you know presumably they will
have done some acting so yeah it's all
goes down to the casting you know you
those are the decisions you make before
you pick the actor is this person
natural is this person uptight is this
person really you know self-conscious
that kind of stuff
yeah it's in the casting
Robert with crowd-sourced Studios and
the films that you plan to make these
are all low-budget films initially yeah
definitely and that's I think that's a
bad thing
typically it used to be when you thought
low-budget you thought crude and cheap
and not crude you know what I mean just
amateur so yeah definitely low-budget
but I think that's I don't think that's
a bad thing I mean I think of like I
said blue ruin or Blood Simple if it was
made today or just simple stories told
well and they're you know it's from a
financial standpoint - I mean the the
the highest-grossing film in terms of
return on investment is Paranormal
Activity that was an $11,000 movie
that's returned two hundred million
dollars so you don't need to spend a lot
of money just to tell a simple story in
addition to which I just I saw Jurassic
world recently and the guy who directed
Jurassic world which is a hundred and
fifty million dollar studio tentpole
juggernaut movie directed one feature
before it was safety not guaranteed
seven hundred fifty thousand dollar
movie right that was his little he went
from the $750,000 movie to a hundred and
fifty million dollar movie so yeah you
can totally prove yourself in a little
movie absolutely yeah Robert for the
writers that submit their scripts to
crowdsource Studios what's in it for
them the competition mm-hmm
same thing as its for directors and
actors and so forth
it's exposure just like most screenplay
competitions they say we're gonna but
what we do differently two things one is
we're gonna probably make the movie you
know if we pick if you win this script
script competition why yeah we're gonna
make your movie a B we are giving gross
points to the
Reiter's the actors and the director
first dollar gross not back in not net
none of that stuff
there's an old saying in Hollywood the
most creative people in Hollywood are
the accountants and so you know net
points you're never gonna see him so um
yeah we're giving first dollar gross
Robert I don't believe anybody else is
doing what you're doing right with
crowds for studios and this is a new
concept is it yeah okay because I
haven't really heard about it yeah are
there anyone else is there any other
company out there or individual who's
doing something similar no no okay there
have been failures in the larger space
like Kevin Spacey had triggers Street
labs I think it was called and Forest
Whitaker had junto Box it was called and
they they're both gone in my view
because of a couple of basic things they
keep it simple I think is an important
rule just really keep it simple don't
complicate it and we try to do that and
I think we accomplished that addition to
which they were financing their own
pictures we're not doing that so they
really needed a home run or a triple at
least you know the or they couldn't
really diversify so we were in a
position where you know Wall Street
thing you know just diversify keep it
period and mmm and the other thing I
think we're doing differently I'm
certain we're doing that nobody else is
doing is we're engaging the audience
right out of the gate you know most
sites they wait to make the movie and
they deal with the filmmaking side of it
and then they hope that the audience
likes it but our members are going to be
our audience so the people that are
voting for the scripts and the actors
and so forth presumably they're going to
be our end users they're gonna watch the
movie and we try to engage them straight
up right right out of the gate how by
having them vote for the script and so
forth so they you know we tell audiences
you pick what do you want to see what
movie do you want to see made who do you
want to see acting in it and I think
that they'll stick around and watch the
finished product
why do you plan to have a social media
person that's going to continue to kind
of engage people or that's a good
question yeah the short answer is yeah
definitely it's it's on the list we have
yeah absolutely it's something I don't
have time to do and and we need a
designated person to do so we're on
Twitter and we're on Facebook but we
just launched soft launch the site a few
weeks ago so what are your handles
it's crowd-sourced I think it's
crowdsource - on Twitter it's all on the
website okay you can yeah there's a link
Robert what's your take on the current
state of the film and television
industry right so um it's an interesting
thing that has happened recently I mean
the numbers are the the box office in
terms of ticket sales had a 20-year low
last year in 2014 and at the same time
the sort of cost benefits are enormous
for studios and the finance Sears
because it used to be when they made a
film it was a film first of all they
shot it on film had it develop it and
produces an actual film P&A costs prints
and advertising was an enormous cost
expense and that's gone now they don't
have to do that anymore and shipping it
around to 2,000 copies of this film to
2,000 studios that expense is gone at
the same time the the exhibitors the
theaters there as I said 20 year low and
that's because there are alternatives
now which there weren't in the past and
I think frankly that's too large degree
I think it's sort of a dying business
model the exhibitors theaters movie
theaters there's certainly something to
be said about going to a theater and
sing a movie and so forth but nowadays
for example I saw a Jurassic world last
week and I had to go to the theater at
12:35 and pay for my ticket and there
was it was not crowded but there was
some guy coughing over here and some
lady be' and it was john pleasant and if
I had a choice to see that at home and
pay at least the same amount I would
probably even pay more on my schedule I
certainly would have done so
so VOD I think you know in a way has
certainly crushed the exhibitors so
that's an interesting sort of thing but
I think the the studios are approaching
it in kind of a foolish way I think
about the music industry and what
happened there so Napster came out right
with the music business and Shawn
Fanning said we found this way to
deliver content really simply a music
industry said let's bury this guy this
guy is a threat to us rather
and it would have been smart for them to
say let's work with this guy this you
know period there's an old theory on
Wall Street that if you have a
competitor and they're a viable threat
to you you can try to crush them and go
to war with them or you can absorb them
and buy them and it's much more sensible
approach to dealing with stuff like that
and they didn't do that and at their
peril so there was a lot of damage as a
result of that Tower Records and so
forth it's all gone and they won the
battle they they shut down Napster but
they lost the war you know their music
business is completely changed so I
think the the studios needs to sort of
embrace that a little bit better than
they're doing now and in terms of the
exhibitors you know these big chains and
so forth I just think about it this way
if there's a family of four people that
they want to go see a movie first of all
to schedule it and to hire a babysitter
and to pay for gas and pay for four
separate admission tickets and so forth
if they have a choice to do that versus
see at home on VOD you know that's an
easy decision
so I think they need to sort of it
shouldn't be one or the other kind of
thing it should I think really think all
movies should just be VOD I really do I
think it's just you know I just think or
at least an option if you want to that a
theater experience and so forth I get
that seeing San Andreas on the big
screen give them the option but it
shouldn't be one or the other in my view
hmm there's a theater near us which I
actually didn't like to go to and now
they've changed it over and now they
have this reclining seats with drink
holders no one kicks your seat behind
you because they're too far right you
can choose your seat ahead of time or
and I'm thinking you know it's actually
worth it for me before I was like for
many years I don't really want to go
there
it's all these loud people and they're
kind of rude and stuff now I actually
don't mind going actually it's an
enjoyable experience now I'm not gonna
see every film there it's not worth it
to me but don't you think that there's
like you said there's certain it's a
magical sort of ethereal experience to
be in this like silent theater with a
bunch of strangers and see an emotional
scene I do I I think you're right you
know I I just I have a theater near me
which is in a small town
it's it was shut down was getting shut
down and these kids sort of
reinvigorated it and they changed the
business model a little bit they
refurbish it's all digital and it's sort
of a nice vibe there it's not this big
corporate sort of you know I definitely
think if I forgive me if I said that
that the theatre industry is dead it's
not it's definitely I think it needs to
be changed and I think frankly it's it's
got a it's got a it's gonna get leaner
and the numbers are gonna continue to
decline but if they can sort of change
things up and make it a more pleasant
experience definitely and there's
undeniably something important about the
experience of seeing it movie
collectively and that kind of stuff I
just think it should it should not be at
the expense of creating an opportunity
for somebody like me who doesn't want to
go to the theater to see that same day
you know day to day and day kind of VOD
I just think it'll supplement them
rather than you know cannibalize them
their business